soit madame merci d'être avec nous une
situation qu'on imagine prévisible
puisqu'elle avait déjà eu lieu comment
expliquer cette pénurie de personnel
médical récurrentes
winnie bonsoir madame en effet comme
vous le dites ça n'est pas la première
fois puisque cet été pendant deux mois
les urgences ont été fermées pendant
deux mois nuit et jour en permanence et
puis là actuellement depuis lundi donc
depuis hier le service d'urgence est
fermé et également le smur c'est à dire
que le le service mobile d'urgence et de
réanimation et ils vous voulez pour
qu'on pète un peu ce que vous disiez
vous dites que les deux hôpitaux sont
sont proches de 12 km mais en fait
l'hôpital de senlis draine tout le
sud-est de luan est en fait d'aider les
habitants qui sont bien plus éloigné de
12 km de l'hôpital de creil puisque
quand on habite nanteuil ou b on est à
peu près à trois quarts d'heure à une
heure de craig bercy qui est déjà un
hôpital totalement saturé donc ça veut
dire alors nous bien sûr vous faites
bien de le préciser on parle est
effectivement de la distance à vol
d'oiseau entre les deux hôpitaux mais on
imagine bien autour et un rayon de
plusieurs kilomètres
ça veut dire quoi des conséquences
potentiellement dramatiques pour les
usagers
bien sûr parce que un habitant de
nanteuil par exemple ou 2b ou de tous
ces petits villages du sud est de luan
seront maintenant à une heure de d'un
service d'urgences et c'est à dire que
si vous faites un infarctus et bien au
mieux au mieux vous aurez le ca le samu
qui arrivera au bout de le smur qui
arrivera au bout de trois quarts d'heure
une heure donc c'est bien évidemment une
perte de chance pour les habitants bien
évidemment en plus l'hôpital de creil
est déjà totalement saturée donc avoir
encore en plus un surcroît de patients
cc c'est absolument à 6 portable pour
les soignants et également pour les
malades vous avez des personnes âgées
qui attendent des heures voire
quelquefois des jours sur des brancards
aux urgences à creil c'est pas
acceptable au 21e siècle ce n'est pas
acceptable la direction elle dit que les
urgences pourrait rouvrir après le
recrutement de trois à quatre médecins
urgentistes qu'est ce qui rend si si
compliqué qu'est ce qui empêche ses
recrutements
alors en fait si vous voulez
d'abord trois ou quatre médecins
urgentistes ça ne pourrait pas couvrir
24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 c'est pas
suffisant et d'autre part
le si vous voulez depuis que l'hôpital
de senlis et fusionner avec l'hôpital de
creil quand vous travaillez à senlis on
peut vous envoyer travailler accès
puisque c'est le même hôpital et c'est
très difficile pour les gens d'accepter
sa perf à l'acceptent mais d'autres
n'accepte pas parce que ils ont
l'impression que c'est un certain mépris
de la part de la direction et puis qu'on
les prend pour des pions pour des
gauches trou et vous voulez ça ne donne
pas un sens ça ne donne pas un sens à
leur travail de se retrouver comme ça
d'un seul coup balancer d'un hôpital à
un autre d'un service à un autre et
c'est très mal vécu par là par le
personnel on imagine que vous vous êtes
bien évidemment rapprocher de la
direction de la santé qui a pris agences
régionales de santé qui a fait cette
décision qu est ce qu on vous répond est
aujourd'hui quelle quelle est l'issue
l'issue je pense que si le
si les habitants ne se mobilise pas si
les élus ne se mobilise pas je pense que
la fermeture des urgences sera entérinée
par l' agence régionale de santé et on
en parlera plus voilà je pense que c'est
ça qui va se passer il faut absolument
que les habitants se mobilisent
que les élus se mobilisent et pâques
pâques le maire qui commence seulement à
se mobiliser et mais tous les élus de
tous les villages du bassin de vie de
qui est drainée par l'hôpital de senlis
c'est à dire fort mille habitants il
faut que tout le monde se mobilise en
plus on est en période préélectorale
donc il faut que tout le monde se
mobilise
en période préélectorale qui on se
mobilise ça va faire bouger les choses
merci beaucoup véronique préveaux
a-bitar présidente du comité de défense
de l'hôpital de senlis merci de nous
avoir apporté votre témoignage